let's go next to our caller from the 408
area code 408 historically has been a
tough area code for us sometimes it goes
great and sometimes it doesn't but let's
see what it is today
who's there from far away Gary can you
hear me
I can't who's this my name is Dakota
I'm calling from Saratoga California
awesome what's on your mind today I
wanted to go ask you for some advice
okay I don't really plan on voting in
the 2018 midterms so what advice and
it's me well I'm just family because why
should I care and why should I vote if
nothing I care about is being talked
about give me an a so it's a we're in
California are you uh Saratoga it's
south of San Jose okay so I just didn't
know where Saratoga was and what do you
care about mental health reform getting
people who are mentally ill you know
better care than what we have now okay
and in what way would they receive
better care and what's going on in the
background there we're on speaker please
take us off and if it sounds like there
is not on speaker you don't be here but
something like that oh I'm at my college
I'll go to a much more quieter area
Saurus and here's the thing Bob I hear
you talking about how mental health
reform is important to you there are two
major ways in which our elected
officials even if they're not talking
about mental health reform specifically
are going to impact mental health reform
number one the discussion around health
care is a huge conversation about mental
health reform because mental health in
our country not only the way that it's
stigmatized but the way that people get
access to it is mostly through the
healthcare system that we have so every
single elected official that's talking
about the health insurance system and
healthcare is talking about your issue
even if they're not using the language
that makes it sound that way number two
the criminal justice system is hugely
connected to mental health and men
health reform so every time that our
elected officials are making decisions
about the criminal justice system they
are dealing with mental health reform
but I want to I want to even go a step
further let's pretend for a second that
nothing our elected officials did
related to mental health reform in any
way that you that you can tell don't we
want to have a stake who's in there so
that we can put people in that are more
likely to be convinced by us to deal
with the issue of mental health reform
like if you say I'm gonna I'm gonna opt
out and just not have a say whatsoever
you now are no longer playing a role in
evaluating who of these candidates is
more likely to be convinced about but
here's the thing they're not treating it
as an important issue they're more
they're treating more stuff like from
whatever Trump's doing as more of an
important issue or right-wing extremism
rather than mentally disturbed people
like this is the wrong approach
think about the $15 minimum wage okay
there haven't been years and years of
Elections that were decided that led to
a point at which the Democratic Party
said we're gonna support a $15 minimum
wage I'm not pretending like this is the
be-all end-all of economic justice or
anything but it's just an example nobody
was talking about a $15 minimum wage for
years when the people that ultimately
decided this will become part of the
Democratic party platform decided okay
if we had opted out of selecting who
represents us during that entire period
you never would have had people in
positions to even be convinced about a
$15 minimum wage so I just think it's
the wrong approach to say because I
don't hear them talking about my one
topic I'm not gonna vote I think it's a
mistake and it's not a neutral act it's
a destructive act and I would encourage
you to vote Dakota
all right thank you I just really think
we the hospitals need better
psychologists and better sort of if they
do evaluations in care because I've been
through the facility and it's basically
a nicer version of prison so to make of
that what you will I don't disagree with
you but you you've got to start by
putting in the people you think are most
likely to hear you on those issues
Dakota thank you I hope you will vote
and I appreciate the call